derniers préparatifs avant une ouverture
exceptionnelle de la cathédrale de jean
linard joyau d'art singulier au coeur du
berry entretenu par l'association autour
de la cathédrale
bien décidé à acquérir le bâtiment on a
créé une scic pour essayer d'acheter ce
lieu une 6 est une société coopérative
d'intérêt collectif
ça fait on l'a créée le 22 juin dernier
et on a actuellement pas loin de 200
sociétaires nous ont fait confiance
et l'idée c'est de d'acheter une par une
par à 20 euros et puis de participer à
la gestion de ce lieu et si la somme est
réunie le premier défi sera la mise aux
normes un sol glissant une toiture à
refaire les travaux sont colossaux ça
pourrait tomber il ya des choses on nous
a demandé de fermer
on a fermé
le choeur de la cathédrale puisque ça
c'est le choeur de la cathédrale donc
voilà l'idée c'est de ne pas envoyer le
public sous des endroits qui pourraient
temps coude est effectivement un coup
devant quelque chose ça pourrait voilà
ça ne préviendra pas si ça tombe des
travaux cher mais indispensable car le
lieu géré par l'association accueille
aujourd'hui du public
voilà l'objet de la discorde avec la
famille héritière de jean linard est
propriétaire des lieux a les moyens de
faire des travaux nécessaires
la famille souhaite que souhaite le
vendre c'est la première option c'est
sur ce c'est ce sur quoi l'unanimité
s'est faite jusqu'à présent
moi à titre personnel que je favoriserai
une institution a un pouvoir public par
exemple capable selon la famille de
gérer le lieu et surtout de l'entretenir